i have a story idea and i'm hoping that
we can see ways to make it
more wild and and really sort of
shake things up from what i have okay
i'm trying to shorten it down but my
character the protagonist is a male in
his 30s
we'll call him derek and he's always
been a techie
he majored in computer science he had a
commodore 64. he's always been very
heady
and flash forward many years later he
gets a very lucrative job at a fortune
500 company
where he's in uh he's in charge of the
sort of i.t department and their
security
and it's a dream job but he's totally
bored there's there's nothing he knows
exactly what his life is and he's
completely bored he becomes a workaholic
he doesn't really meet
any romantic partners until one day he
goes to a coffee shop
and a very attractive young woman asks
for help
with her computer well it turns out
unbeknownst to him
he's been targeted by a rival company
and they want to use
her to seduce him so that they can get
into
the company's mainframe and find out
trade secrets
so uh her name is skyler what a perfect
name for
for that character and at first when he
realizes he's being used he's upset and
then he realizes he doesn't care anymore
and he's willing because his life really
wasn't what he wanted
and he's fallen in love with this woman
and he knows
that he's being manipulated and he
doesn't care
so um he feels that he can change skylar
and give her a better life
and that anyway
help me out here how can i make this
story better
give it more sort of a wow factor really
shock people with it well it's not just
mere shock value it's
the thing that i would focus on first is
um what's his name again derek
derrick um would be a
good strong dilemma for derek being
trapped between two equally
unacceptable alternatives
a good example of that would be in the
movie training day
where the ethan hawk character jake is
caught in a good strong dilemma between
his
his ambition to make it on to
the denzel washington characters
undercover narcotics squad his ambition
he's very ambitious
and his moral compass because he's
willing to do anything
to make that squad because he wants to
make detective and get his own division
you know become a high-ranking cop
and his ambition is his weakness
so he's overly ambitious and yet he has
a strong moral compass too
so as alonso drags him deeper and deeper
into
the basically the trap that alonso has
set for him
his ambitions are being realized he's
moving
forward aggressively and seeing a path
but
that also includes corruption and
questionable activities so his moral
compass is rebelling
so he can't let go of his ambition
nothing will make him let go of his
ambition
but he can't let go of his moral compass
either
and they're really equally strong
so that's an example of a good strong
dilemma
so i would the first thing i would focus
on
is a potential dilemma for
derek because there's either a dilemma
inherent in the story idea that
you've pitched or there isn't
if it's there then i want to isolate it
and then amplify it to maximize its
strength
if it's not there i would experiment
with creating one
and and i'm not trying to force a
dilemma onto it
because the story's the most important
thing
but a good strong dilemma can
amplify the dramatic power of a story
and so
i look at the possibility of creating
one without
forcing it or bending the story out of
shape
in this one it seems like there is
a dilemma kind of sitting on the surface
in other words
i'm not having to go is there one in
there i can see it right there because
it's unacceptable to go along
with the manipulation
and generally the dilemma kicks in
somewhere and then around the end of act
one you have to like
live with the character for a while get
to know them get to care about the lead
pro the protagonist and for the story to
develop
um to the point where somewhere around
the end of act one the protagonist
finds him or herself caught in a dilemma
of magnitude
magnitude means significance to an
audience
does it hit them where they live does it
grab them is it important
like you could have a dilemma that it's
unacceptable to wash the car
it's equally unacceptable to mow the
lawn that is in fact a dilemma
but it's not going to grab an audience
it doesn't have magnitude
so so
if after a whole act
one he's noticing that he's the subject
of a manipulation
and he's like i'm not gonna allow
myself to i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
fall for this i'm not going down that
road
and yet we're looking for something
that's
equally unacceptable that like
it's unacceptable to let go of this
kind of wild card that has
disrupted his
predictable career trajectory
which reminds me of the story of the
musician sting
from the police he was the headmaster of
a girls school
in england and he said at one point
he had a a flash where he could see the
whole rest of his life in this
really predictable path and he was like
like whoa i am not doing that like let
me out of here
and he's like you know he's like i like
music i'm
i'm gonna chase that hard so there's
something similar
in derek going
i don't like
the trap that she's leading me into
but i do like the trap she's leading me
into
and so there is that's why i'm saying i
could see a dilemma sitting on the
surface there is a dilemma
inherent in the material which
then now that we have isolated
the the two halves of the dilemma
then the next step that i would do would
be to
experiment with amplifying
each of those halves
so
if i'm him and one way i do it is i i
put myself
in derek's shoes so if i'm derek
and not only all my training
in terms of security and i.t and
lockdown
and watching the companies back and
keeping predators out and knowing that
they're out there
trade secrets and all that kind of stuff
that i'm naturally
not only a guard dog
but an attack dog um
[Music]
so like it's unacceptable
to let anybody outsmart me
in this stuff because i'm protecting my
master and i'll
i'll take a bullet for them you know
it's the attack dog the secret service
all that stuff is kind of like
wired into him and there's a
professional
ferocity that like nobody's getting
around me
i'm the goalie nobody's scoring on me
and i don't care if i dislocate my arm
and i never play again they're not
putting that puck in that net
the more that that aspect of his
personality can be amplified
the more what we're doing is we're we're
jacking up that side of the dilemma
by playing what if with what are the
things that it's like putting a jack
under it and jacking it up a little
and at first it'll go right up and then
it'll be like you can still get one more
click out of it and like what's the most
intense you can make it
and and there's a variety of factors
that would inform that and go into that
one of the things you see often is a
past failure
where he's not going to let it happen
again or
and maybe that goes hand in glove with a
character defect on himself
or but it's really just like
like my dog will die to keep you from
hurting my kids
that kind of thing you are not getting
past
that watchdog
so amplifying that
and then and you can see how that it's
not that hard
to beef that up to make him a ferocious
guard dog and and
and yet because he's also
like bored
um dead-ended
and potentially also has that kind of
revelation that
sting had of like oh my god i can see
the whole rest of my life and
i'd really rather shoot myself than go
down that path
so
there's something
that awakens
a rebellious streak in him an
adventurous streak
um a kink
you know just a fascinating fascination
with this
young woman and
it's almost like
an opportunity presents itself
to break out of jail
so
it's kind of a wild streak in this
character
it's almost like a tiger that's been
raised in a zoo
and is domesticated in a lot of ways get
its food delivered to it
all that stuff but some of its
wild instincts arise
and it has a
profound hunger to pursue that
and and
the thing to also bear in mind that as
i'm playing with this this
is wildly unformed
in my mind so that i'm literally
sitting here with
a couple things in my hand and nothing
else
uh so i can see how to amplify
that part of him that is no way you're
getting around me
over my dead body but then
what i'm also looking at and i got that
that's not going away that's
not so hard we can probably complicate
that
as the story progresses or we'll stumble
over ways that are obvious that we
haven't noticed yet to make that
even stronger but that's not
complicated from one point of view this
is an
interesting puzzle to make this side of
the dilemma
more unacceptable more powerful more
dynamic
and so all the reasons why he can't let
go
of the opportunity that she presents
including her he's just fascinated with
her as a possible mate
even if he's already married or maybe
his marriage is dead and who knows that
these are all
things to play with as you play what if
with the dilemma
but
that part of him
you know for instance like a crazy what
if like what if
like in lethal weapon he goes home and
puts a gun to his mouth and is thinking
about suicide like he's so
dead end in this job and hates it that
maybe he's attempted suicide before and
nobody ever knew
i don't know maybe he just plays with
the rifle with a handgun at home
that would complicate
it gives him more of a flaw which you
tend to want to have and
complicates his
approach to
the riddle that she presents for him
internally
i think that clearly if he's great at
his job
that he has several different options
like he could just
shut her out and walk away and there but
then there's no
dilemma there's no story but that's one
of the options
once he begins to notice what she's up
to he's like
i'm out of here you know screw you i'm
how why would you do this to me and
you're not my friend and
we're not going down this road and he
just pulls the plug and it's done
maybe they got into a little bit of
something and he just covers it back up
or changes something and
what they got didn't amount to anything
and he just
drops the firewall on them but what
you're suggesting
is quite a bit different than that
is that that that part of him which is
starving for some fresh air
can't let go of this opportunity and
won't
and even if it ends up
that he ultimately goes over to the dark
side and completely betrays his company
and that gets him out of his
trap you know it's like the bear chewing
its leg off to get out of a leg hold
trap
that may be one of his options or
that may be
see there's one thing to be trapped in a
good strong dilemma
and that generally kicks in around the
end of act one after we've gotten to
know the character
and get the story developed to a point
that dilemma builds an intensity all
throughout
act two until around the end of act two
it comes to a critical juncture
where it comes to the make or break
point because with dilemma
you really can't choose either way like
jake in
training day cannot let go of his
ambition and cannot let go of his moral
compass
the crisis in training day comes
when alonzo tries to have him killed by
the hillside gang the latino gang
in that house up on the hill and they're
about to blow his brains out in the
bathtub
i'm not going to say anything more about
the story because i don't want to spoil
it for people who haven't seen it
but that's part way through it i'm not
going to talk about the ending at all
but that crisis
forces a decision in action about the
dilemma
so that the crisis demands an
immediate decision and action about the
dilemma
that the protagonist is still stuck in
and the protagonist
once the dilemma comes to this critical
juncture the crisis which is out around
the
three-quarters point in the story
the protagonist has to make some kind of
decision and take some kind of action
that breaks the paralysis of the dilemma
so they're now in a fight to the finish
to try to resolve the dilemma
so as i'm wrestling with
derek's dilemma and looking at
amplifying it making it more powerful
more riveting to the audience
and part of that is playing crazy what
if that's what i'm talking about like
don't settle for the easy choices how
far can you take it
how much can you make this protagonist
scream because of this dilemma
the more impossible it is for them
the more the audience comes up on the
edge of their seat because this is
our hero in this story and they're
caught in a bad situation
and if that dilemma is universal which
you tend to want to do then the audience
is sitting there going
i understand this dilemma because i'm
caught in something like this
you know of like a duty versus honor
dilemma
or whatever that may not be i
that's not necessarily and that's
probably not a good description of this
particular dilemma
but let me let me so let me retract and
articulate his dilemma with that level
of simplicity so
duty and honor is definitely there no
way
they're getting around me but no way
am i letting go of this
whacked out left-handed opportunity
that blindsided me and reawakened
my starvation for adventure and freedom
and unpredictability so really it's a
security versus adventure dilemma
which is very universal like
no way am i letting go of my security
but there's no way i'm letting go of my
adventure
it's like it sucks being a bank teller
but
it sucks trying to make it as a painter
living on peanut butter sandwiches
i can't let go of the security but i
can't let go of my need for adventure
so i i think that's an accurate
representation at first glance
of derek's dilemma so
his and i would say that he has a part
of his personality makeup
is a deep-seated need
for security and predictability
and to be a good watchdog but there's
also the contradictory part of his
personality
that's starving for adventure and fresh
air and
to get out get out of that cubicle and
start really living life
so not only
does skyler
and her masters
present
an unexpected opportunity
but that the deeper
derek gets in as you progress through
act two
and this dilemma gets more and more
intense
as things keep ratcheting up that it
becomes
more acceptable to let them
get around him but it's also more
acceptable
more unacceptable to let go of this
dynamic
once in a lifetime opportunity
and you know and
some of that would probably have to do
with
the nature of the business that business
that he's protecting
and the intentions of
the uh predator who's operating
schuyler and and you know those are
things to play with for instance
is the company that derek works for
maybe the more derek
is exposed to what skyler
is talking about and probably what
her boss is telling her to say
maybe derek begins to perceive that the
company he's
vigilantly protecting is actually either
a criminal operation
or is doing something morally
reprehensible
that makes this side stronger
but maybe what they're going to do with
it is
highly questionable or criminal or
whatever so the need to protect
so there's there's story possibilities
that can go
in wildly different directions
um and
you know so much of that has to do with
your intention as a storyteller
where you want to steer the story versus
listening to the story like
it basically comes down to
what the tools that you're using as a
dramatist
suggest in terms of story possibilities
and
dramatizing the material so that it
stays active and gripping to an audience
there's like there's like the demands of
the story and the demands of the tools
and you want to really listen to both of
them
the tools will suggest certain things
the story will suggest
certain things and you want to really
factor them both in like
the the um
the technique the techniques of the
various tools involved may suggest that
you steer the story in this direction
but your intention
as a storyteller or as the story takes
on a life of its own
it may really want to go in this
direction and you want to really
be responsive to that the story is the
most important thing
the tools are a mere technique that can
help you shape the story to
make it work dramatically
so it's a given take between
what the story the energy that the story
brings to the table and your intentions
for
what the story brings versus
the technique that you bring to the
table
so it's kind of like a synthesis
of the two
and so
you know as i
work with
making the dilemma more and more intense
and riveting and entertaining or
compelling
you know it may be a brutal thriller so
it's not like an action comedy at all so
entertainment value is absolutely like
how's this gonna turn out i can't look
away
somebody's gonna die here you know it
can be brutally intense and
really riveting so it's not like
entertainment value and like haha funny
but it's just like
they couldn't pay you to to leave the
theater before it ends
um so that
as i build that dilemma toward
the the critical juncture around the end
of act ii
when that dilemma becomes a crisis and
forces
an immediate decision in action about
that dilemma
now that it's gone critical it's like a
gun to the head that demands em
you don't you don't get to contemplate
your dilemma from a distance anymore
going what am i gonna do when
it goes critical now it has gone
critical and it's like the gun is to the
head and
you got to make a decision right now and
take an action
and you're like i can't make a decision
so that's
it's it's riveting but as i'm
amplifying the dilemma what i'm looking
at is the point on the horizon that it's
all going to converge toward
at the two-thirds point around the end
of act two
that what does not what does what is
shaping up as the potential
crisis as i build the dilemma
in other words there could be a whole
lot of factors
that go into constituting the crisis
which informs the trajectory of the
dilemma
because often a crisis is all the worst
possible stuff happening at the worst
possible moment
and sometimes the crisis can involve
that you're
it's not like all catastrophic failure
all at the same time
which is definitely part of a crisis
where everything's caving in on you at
the worst possible moment
but it can also be like that you're
right on the edge of succeeding
right as it all goes to hell you're like
i'm an inch away from pulling this off i
had a way out i can do this
and it all cascades into failure so it's
not all just
it's all going wrong but part of it it's
all going right and this is the worst
possible thing at the worst possible
moment
so it's a mixture of the two and
it's so
as i build the dilemma the possibilities
for the crisis
inform the choices that i'm making
because it's like how can i make this as
gripping as possible
as it gets denser and more complex and
more compelling
and that's where you know like what i'm
talking about about don't make
sedate choices you know it's about
entertainment value about it's about
outrageousness
and that doesn't mean just
mere wacky stuff or blowing more things
up but it's like
as he wrestles with his dilemma as
things get more and more intense
she i would think is
perhaps flowering as a person
in their relationship that she's like
the best thing that ever happened to him
but she may also be the worst thing
that's ever happened to him like she's
creating him she's turning him into a
new person but she's also destroying him
so that he can't hang on and he can't
let go
and she's like wildly the love of his
life
but he still can't jump ship because
he's gonna
lose his life maybe in the process of
making his life
so it's an aggressive experimentation
with pure storytelling
and pure technique and synthesizing the
two
where the technique suggests ramping up
the intensity more and more and more
until it's at the
like it's like at a point of the engine
is
screaming and about to vibrate to pieces
and then everything really goes wrong
at that like at the worst possible
moment
a whole other monkey wrench gets thrown
into the thing
so it's all like playing with options
um is that helpful
yeah i love it i love it and i'm
wondering is there something that's just
dilemma
that's just one part of one of the seven
tools
but that's where i go first right and
i'm wondering what
where could like a meteor come from
another plant
and just like just destroy all
expectations because we figure there's
probably going to be two outcomes one of
two
either he's able to quote unquote save
her and give her this good life maybe
she never had
and that's why she would do such a thing
and she needed the money and she got in
with some bad people or um
he's going to he has such a strong moral
compass that he's going to say
sorry i can't do this i not only am i
going to ruin my career
but my parents and all my high school
friends and college friends they're
never going to see me the same
and i'm going to end up in the papers
and so but then
what could be a third thing that could
just come from nowhere that we don't see
because those seem like two likely
outcomes well there's
two avenues to explore in that question
one of which has to do with
informal logic they talk about dilemma
as being caught on the horns of a
dilemma
two equally unacceptable alternatives
either one will gore you
you can't you can't go either way
and they talk about different ways to
resolve a dilemma one is that you can
pick one of the horns
or the other you can pick one of the
unacceptable alternatives
and go all the way become a
revolutionary with her destroy the
company that he was in or
throw her to the become a more
rigorous guardian of the he could he
could go he could pick one of those two
unacceptable alternatives and go all the
way with it
and resolve his dilemma or by thinking
on his feet
he could come up with a radically third
alternative
in which he's not choosing either one of
the things that he was trapped in
it's like somebody saying you got to go
through that door or you got to go
through that door
and by thinking on your feet you get a
chainsaw and
cut a third door and go out that way
it's about it by thinking on your feet
you come up with a creative resolution
they call it the third path in the
science of dilemma
and so often in a story like this
the protagonist does
find a third way out um
there's a great example of that in the
firm
but let me just say spoiler spoiler
alert
and if you don't if you haven't seen the
firm which is a phenomenal movie
hit pause fast forward a little bit
because it's a great example but i don't
want to ruin the movie for people either
so in in the firm tom cruise is in this
high-paying law firm and he finds out
it's actually
owned by the mafia and he gets put in a
good strong dilemma
by ed harris this aggressive fbi agent
who says
you have to um bring
us proof that they are
involved in a criminal enterprise or we
are going to
ruin your life and if he brings proof
then he violates
his oath as a lawyer if he does what the
fbi wants
he'll be permanently disbarred because
he divulged client privileged
information
but if he doesn't do what they're saying
they'll ruin his life
it's something like that i i don't know
if i'm saying it exactly right
but it's very much in the ballpark he
finds a creative third way out
in that when
he when one of the people he's working
with
mentions that they have been
systematically over
billing him which they're doing to
everybody and they make a lot of money
on that and it's criminal
the guy that he's the client that he's
talking to says what they don't realize
is when they put a stamp on this
that became a federal crime and tom
cruise lies light up and he's like
yes and each single act is is punishable
by
you know ten thousand dollar fine and
ten years and each one of those and
he goes i just studied that for the bar
exam and he's like
and so what he does he
he does not do what the fbi demands of
him but he does not go down with this
criminal law
firm either is that he gives the fbi
proof of them systematically over
billing the clients
through the mail each of which is a
federal crime
and it wasn't this huge bust that the
fbi wanted
but a lot of little busts that have real
teeth and add up to a lot of prison time
but it's a lot of hard work for the fbi
but he gave them
by the letter of the law what they were
demanding without violating
attorney-client privilege
so he skated between these two equally
unacceptable alternatives by coming up
with a radical third alternative
that result that's that conclusively
resolved his dilemma
and made for a satisfying ending to the
movie
and so that would be the type of thing
that could work very well
in this type of story so that for
instance
if for instance there were some
questionable activities that his
the organization that he's guarding is
involved with
and the predator wants to get at that
it's kind of like the predator is
putting him in an all or nothing
position
but he finds a way
to maybe
undo some of the questionable activities
that his
the organization that he's guarding is
involved with
without violating them without
exposing their hard drive it merely
opens up to public scrutiny one thing
that they're doing
that they really shouldn't be doing
doesn't and allows the predator to make
that public
without hurting the company so he kind
of
skates between
the trap that he's in and maybe takes
the girl with him
as a mate something like that in which
he finds a creative
third way out of the impossible
situation that he was stuck in
i like that so he's this that's the door
that he's
right okay and by thinking on his feet
he came up with a
creative third resolution
possibility where there used to be only
two because maybe
this this sort of um this this act of
espionage that they want them to do is
because maybe
they've compiled information on their
customer base and they really shouldn't
have kept that and not disclosed or
something
so what if he somehow i don't know turns
it around so that that that's no longer
there
or then the customers are notified every
so somehow it's like there's a
resolution
i don't know how that would be done it
should also be something of magnitude
if it's if it's a minor offense then the
audience will go so what who cares
so that's where the magnitude where you
it gets up to a level of like oh that's
important i care about that
right but that's just a factor you know
that's something to factor in as
you build that half of the dilemma
and it's informed by if the if the
predator who's operating the young woman
is showing him things that are
questionable about the organization he's
guarding and he's like yeah you're right
they are you know but you just wanted to
come above a certain threshold of
questionability right so don't that's
all the particulars of the story
sure so so forge the third path that
sounds like
don't take the right don't take the left
try to dig
that's just one possible resolution for
this type of story
well it would probably be too
predictable don't you think if if
i chose one or the other if i chose it
where
somehow he turned these people in and
was able to
to still keep his job and then
he marries her and they live happily
ever after in the suburbs
and and i mean that's i don't know if
that's really going to work
um or if he absconds with her to
the cayman islands and then he's hiding
for the rest of his life
that's not going to work either so right
or you know
he he escapes
the substantial trap that the predator
laid for him
and escapes the trap
of his um
rut his career predictable career rut
and potentially some criminality that
his or
that the organization he's guarding was
involved in
so that he kind of outsmarts
his boss and outsmarts the predator and
maybe
runs away with the girl and they
hitchhike around the world i mean like
he completely drops out of
the whole arena he was in you know it's
just a
part of a creative a a possible creative
solution
to the complex trap that he was stuck in
and he becomes a consultant that does
like white hat pen testing types
or he may never look at a computer again
they may steal a sailboat and
sail off you know with a hundred
thousand dollars in cash in the hold and
that's all they have but it's he's
completely free from everything
there's you know there's so many ways
you can go with the story ending
but you wanted to impact the audience
powerfully and
make them
feel different than the way they came
into the theater
you know they want to be transformed
even transfigured
even like to the point where they never
think the same way again for the rest of
their life it like
permanently changes how their brain is
wired that's what people hope for
in a great story that it completely
changes how you see the world forever
most stories don't do that but the best
ones
can do that
and it's fun to aspire to
you